you assume the worst in people
which well
maybe we're not so different after all
who are you over there
what are you hiding
are you just
hideously scarred
listen to me
if we don't stand up for annika no one
will
all anyone cares about in this place are
these white privileged
the mayor the commissioner the d.a now
thomas and bruce wayne i mean as far as
i'm concerned that psycho's right to go
after these creeps i think you'd be on
his side what do you mean thomas and
bruce wayne why do you live in a cave
the rid there's latest it's all about
the wings
listen if i can find that dick bag
kenzie will you help me
please
come on vengeance
don't make any moves without me
understand
so more dangerous than you
i told know baby
i can take care of myself
[Music]
you